Question 1 - Mr Resident Evil asks, Do you
think Clara has been moving away from the
Doctor because of his regeneration and how
do you think she’ll leave
the show?
Question 2 - Luke asks Is Clara in the next
episode?
I didn’t see her
in the trailer but the BBC Guide says she’s
on the train
with
the Doctor?
Question 3 - Elva asks, what do you think
about The Doctor telling Courtney she wasn’t
special?
This seemed like the opposite of what he would
normally do.
Question 4 - Rachel asks, where do you think
the Doctor went when he left?
Question 5 - Joey asks, how do you feel about
them doing all stand alone episodes this year
and no two parters?
Question 6 - a person asks, what
was the last episode you hated?
Question 7 - Dragon Girl asks, do you think
the Doctor made the decision to not intervene
because of what happened in Waters of Mars
with Adelaide Killing
Herself
Question 8 - Peter asks, what do you think
will happen to Clara after this?
Question 9 - Dav asks, we’ve seen a lot
of “Last of it’s kind” or “Only one
of it’s kind” creatures, is there any
special meaning
in that?
Question 10 - Fresh Plays asks, does the Doctor
really
have infinite Regenerations?